did Google just embarrass Apple well
today we will see because we're gonna be
comparing everything from the design the
displays speakers features performance
and more I've been a fan of pixel
devices 4 for a while but the last few
years they just really weren't that
great but this pixel 7 Pro is different
and taking a look at that I don't know
what do you call it unibrow or whatever
it definitely looks nicer than the
camera bump on the iPhone 14 plus and I
gotta say I'm not really a fan of the
midnight on the plus because it shows so
many fingerprints and the camera bump is
just all dark so overall I would say
looks wise I'd give it to the pixel and
with that as far as the comfort in the
hand I do have a little bit better grip
on the iPhone because the square edges
but the rounded glass and rounded edges
of the pixel are a little bit more
comfortable I also like that the buttons
are all on the right hand side on the
pixel instead of being split on the
iPhone and even though both of these are
made out of aluminum I would say that
the polished aluminum which looks like
stainless steel that also goes into that
camera bump feels just a little bit more
premium than the iPhone with that it
also weighs a little bit more it's also
a little thicker in the body and quite a
bit thicker where the camera bump is or
maybe it just looks that way because
it's a single piece and that's also
because it packs a lot of extra camera
features as well as extra battery inside
and we'll talk about battery in just a
bit now you may ask why are we comparing
it to the plus not the pro Max well
these are the same size they have the
same screens they have the same storage
and they're the exact same price with
that we have a lot of screen differences
but before I get into that first I want
to compare the speakers pixels used to
have amazing dual front firing speakers
but then it got a lot worse so let's go
and take a listen to what we have with
the 7 Pro
somewhere unfamiliar
[Music]
wow guys that was crazy the pixel was
winning everything up until this point
but the 14 Plus speakers demolished it
and yes I did turn on the Adaptive sound
and then made the sound quality better
that's what you guys heard but the
iPhone is still so far ahead because as
the same speakers from the pro Max now
if you're gonna be buying any of the new
iPhone 14 models you're definitely gonna
have to get a reliable case like one of
the new iPhone 14 impact cases from our
sponsor case defy which are engineered
with the new twister design known as
ecoshock which provides 20 increased
protection compared to the previous
generation up to five times the military
standard which means it's been drop
tested over 130 times to ensure ecoshock
doesn't wear off and they're sustainably
made with 65 recycled and plant-based
materials they're all very high quality
and they're now available with more
prints than ever before and you can get
them with maxi of compatibility for all
of your accessories like wireless
chargers and wall and of course we put
the new Ultra impact case with the
ecoshock protection designed to the test
by drop testing our iPhone 14 with it
coming out basically good as new since
it has drop protection up to 11 and a
half feet high so check out one of Casey
phi's new iPhone 14 cases using the link
down below and save 15 off your order
today now getting into displays the
iPhone has that Notch while the pixel
has that little cutout for the camera
now that can be used for Face Unlock as
you guys see right there it unlocks it
and I can swipe to open it up now the
iPhone of course has face ID and the
iPhones is more secure than just a
simple camera now because of that the
pixel still has a fingerprint scanner
underneath the display and that can be
used to unlock the phone and for things
like secure payments the pixel also has
noticeably thinner bezels and that is
helped out by the curve on the screen as
far as the screen inequality the pixel
is much sharper but you do have to make
sure to go in the settings and enable
that full resolution instead of the
default of 1080p thankfully smooth
display is turned on by default which
will adjust from 60 hertz up to a much
smoother 120 hertz whereas the 14 pro is
always stuck at 60 hertz which means it
is not as smooth as you guys can see by
this slow motion footage honestly I
really think this is a shame and apple
should have at least put a 90 Hertz in
this screen now the pixel also has an
always-on display Google hides that in
the lock screen and then you have to
enable always show time and info and
then you'll be able to see the always on
display whereas the 14 plus does not
have that you have to spend another 200
to get the pro Max in order to get that
you may have noticed that all of these
features say that they're going to use
more battery we have the full quality of
the display we have the always on mode
and even by default we have the Dark
theme enabled and that is because even
though the pixel 7 Pro has a larger
battery the battery life will not last
as long and a part of that is the
processor the tensor G2 chip whereas the
iPhones it's just more efficient as far
as brightness the pixels have never been
that bright so I'm gonna go ahead and
turn them up all the way here and even
though the pixel has gotten brighter the
14 plus still beats it out in manual
mode at least here indoors turning on
auto brightness and heading outside now
the pixel is noticeably brighter which
is nice but if we enable dark mode and
look at a web page the brights really
pop now and that enables it to get the
full 1500 nits so I suggest keeping the
dark mode turned on so you can get the
full advertised brightness whereas the
iPhone can only reach a thousand nits
now of course the 14 pro Max can hit 2
000 nits so if you guys want to see our
full comparison against that phone make
sure you guys click that subscribe
button down below now as far as HDR
video I was really surprised that the
iPhone is not only brighter but it has
better contrast as well and that is what
the pixel's defaulted adaptive screen
mode not the natural mode the brights
really pop on the iPhone the contrast
stands out and I think that is because
apple is using a nicer more expensive
display that does have more contrast now
of course if we go full screen that
Notch is distracting compared to the
pixel but if we're looking at the image
quality by itself the iPhone is clearly
Superior and now let's get into
performance so far the pixels won
everything but two categories let's see
what the tensor G2 can do I'm gonna go
ahead and start the CPU test here and as
you guys could see the pixel has 12
gigabytes of RAM compared to six gigs on
the 14 plus and we have a result results
and I will just say that the tensor G2
is not doing that well as far as single
core we have 1745 compared to
1057. that is 65 faster and the iPhone
doesn't even have the latest processor
it has the a15 from last year and as far
as multi-core we have a difference of 45
that is a big difference and both of
these are five nanometer processors now
of course the pixel is still nice and
fast and you're not really going to
notice that day to day but where that
will come in is two three years down the
line the iPhone will still be super fast
where the pixel might start falling
behind now what I'm curious about is
graphics performance I have 3D Mark
opened up right here Renee's Wildlife
extreme in that unlimited mode so we can
test out the full performance and let's
see how the tensor G2 does in terms of
Graphics the scores are in and we have a
difference of about 50 percent in favor
favor of the iPhone we have 10.7 FPS
compared to 15.7 now that doesn't sound
like a big difference but keep in mind
this is a very difficult test and it
just shows you how far ahead the a15 is
compared to the tensor G2 now as far as
cameras Google really stepped it up we
have that main camera that has 50
megapixels compared to 12 megapixels on
the iPhone it also has a 5x Optical
telephoto camera which is 48 megapixels
whereas the iPhone doesn't even have one
both of the ultra wides are 12
megapixels and as far as their
front-facing cameras we have 12
megapixels on the iPhone compared to 10
but one thing I noticed is just how long
the pixel takes to switch modes it is
crazy long now supposedly the video's
gone a lot better this year and you guys
know how we like to do it we're gonna do
another blind camera comparison where
I'm gonna shoot photos of a demon
jellica are going to choose that that's
always a ton of fun and that will be
coming out tomorrow you don't want to
miss it so make sure you're subscribed
now with that said the pixel also has
some very unique features they have this
new on blur tool that can take blurry
photos and sharpen them also this clear
calling mode that uses the tensor cores
to take out background sound Google's
doing some cool stuff with this tensor
processor the overall which phone is
better well other than the HDR the
performance of the processor and the
speakers I have to give it to the pixel
7 Pro for the money you are getting a
lot of value you have the stock softer
here which is very nice so even as an
iPhone fan I have to say that the pixel
7 Pro is definitely the better phone
compared to the iPhone now we'll have to
see how it compares to the iPhone 14 pro
max if you guys want to see that click
that Circle above to subscribe and check
out one of those great videos right over
there this Max and I will see you in the
next video
[Music]